Eternals assemble I saw him on tv
with the cape tuning laser beams
i don't wear a cape. Are you wizard
like doctor strange i'm super normal
Welcome back everyone this will be my full
marvel eternals movie breakdown easter eggs
for the entire movie there's so much stuff to talk
about so many wtf moments and setting up so much
big stuff for the future of the mcu so if you're
brand new to the channel be sure to subscribe to
get all the videos we're doing a giveaway for
movie tickets and disney plus memberships all
you have to do to enter is just be a subscriber
and leave your favorite easter egg or reference
or moment from the movie on the video careful
for spoilers if you have not seen the movie
yet because we'll be talking about everything
i did just do a big post credit scene and mid
credit scene video so i'll link that at the end
of this so you can watch that after this or down
in the description below if you haven't seen it
yet but at the very beginning of the movie they
have the very first opening crawl that they've
ever used in a marvel movie ever and the funny
thing is is that most of this opening crawl is a
lie it lies about what the eternal's real mission
is reads like celestial propaganda it's the
dogma that the eternals have been fed every
time they get their memories reset the opening
crawl also tries to tell you that arishem the
judge was created before the infinity stones were
created like he created the very first sun in the
very first galaxy of the universe right after the
big bang but here's the thing there are so many
contradictory points here and if you know real
world science like if you paid attention in grade
school science then you know how the big bang
works you know how galaxies form around suns you
know how gravity works so the whole idea in the
movie is that ereshan the judge is probably lying
about almost everything now he tells them some
truths about what happened in their true history
but i think they're buried in lies like half
truths buried in lies so you're meant to question
everything that you read in this opening crawl
like wait a minute this probably is not totally
accurate the crawl also lies about the true
origin of the deviants the eternals it doesn't
mention the celestial world forge and it also
lies presenting ereshan the judge and the other
celestials like their infallible gods whose gospel
everyone should worship cut to later in the movie
when arishem full-on admits that he made a mistake
when he created the deviants and he lost control
of them like how powerful could he possibly be
if he's this god who can't control the deviants
it's all part of this scam that the celestials
are running is part of their grand design
it's sort of a wink of thanos's grand design like
thanos's plan to balance half of all life in the
universe and that would fix everything there's
also a sly reference to that when they talk about
everything being in balance during the opening
crawl perfectly balanced is all things should
be but the idea is that there's always a better
way so the whole idea is that the celestials have
this grand design but there's probably a better
way to accomplish what it is they're trying to do
but because they're so powerful no one has ever
challenged that plan before so if the deviants
can escape his judgment then that means so can the
eternals like even when harry styles eros starfox
shows up at the end of the movie he's another
prime celestial like ajak and like sersi becomes
during the movie it's implied that he's not in
the middle of any kind of mission to burr the new
celestial so if he's gone off book and been able
to escape arishem's judgment then that means other
eternals can do that as well like your story isn't
quite adding up here and that stuff that they'll
get into during the sequels is them laying the
seeds to make another celestial reference of the
celestial's own downfall ultimately at the
hands of the other eternals and potentially
other powerful beings clearly from the side of
nowhere and guardians of the galaxy celestials
can be killed with sufficient power also they
wind up killing tiamat at the end of the movie
using the uni-mind i mean they turn him to stone
but effectively he's dead celestials are supposed
to be the most powerful cosmic beings that we met
so far in the mcu they were not affected by thanos
snap one because they're not technically alive and
thanos was only snapping life the whole key though
is in the uni-mind at the end of the movie sersi
becomes this focal point of their uni-mind the
receptacle for all their combined cosmic energy
and they reveal that she also gains an extra power
up when the uni-mind connects them to tiamat's
power so the uni-mind kind of leeches off of his
cosmic energy giving them the power boost that
she needs to transform him into stone so they were
able to do that to kill that celestial with just
a handful of eternals then if they can find other
eternals in other parts of the universe and form a
larger uni-mind then they can kill more celestials
but if you take it at face value what arishem
tells to sersi is that over billions of years
what's happened is that he's the prime
celestial the one that was created first
he created the first son that led to the creation
of the first galaxy in the universe then as his
cycle of birthing other celestials continued
and more and more celestials rose up and they
created more and more galaxies more and more suns
he planted thousands of celestial seeds all over
the universe in different galaxies and he explains
that this cycle is necessary in order to help the
universe continue existing like it would fall to
its heat death faster if they didn't continue to
create more celestials that created more suns
creating more galaxies connecting this now to
the loki series and he who remains king we saw the
end of the main mcu universe timeline the sacred
timeline and there were no more celestials here
he who remains is called that because he literally
is the last remaining living being in the universe
at this point in the timeline so that confirms
that at some point in the timeline irishman
the judge and the other celestials have to die
the movie jumps all over the timeline you see the
origin of the universe according to eresham if you
believe him at face value like i said i think
that he's lying a little bit he's being kind of
misleading about the true origin of the universe
and the way he was created early on during his
cycles of birthing new celestials he created the
deviants as he says he lost control of them then
created the eternals to correct that mistake in
each time they burn the new celestial they'll just
wipe the memories of the eternals on that planet
and send them to another planet to do the same
thing again over millions and millions of years so
the eternal's main characters in the movie aren't
even the original eternals that's a big jack kirby
eternal's comic book reference in the comics ajak
ikaris sersi thena all the main characters
are the children of other older eternals
but in the comics they're not robots they're just
highly evolved humans who were modified by the
celestials making another thanos connection thanos
parents came from earth originally so thanos has a
connection to earth and away mcu thanos does not
also thanos and thena are cousins in the comics
i know there are a lot of questions
about how thanos and harry styles eros
can both be the children of eternals if eternals
technically are robots that can't have children
don't worry i'll explain that later in the video
but the place they land their ship the domo is
in mesopotamia about 7000 years ago because that's
believed to be the cradle of civilization on earth
as civilization had just started to form so that's
where the deviants start attacking because at this
point in history it's the biggest population
center the whole idea being that the celestial's
actual plan the grand design is to have the
eternals help humans increase their populations
as fast as possible on all these different worlds
because the celestial seed of tiamat inside the
earth needs to feed off this low-level cosmic
energy given off by life forms they don't have
to be humans because they do this all over the
universe on other planets where they're alien
species that aren't quite as humanoid but in order
to fully mature a new celestial a certain amount
of population is required ajak claims that had
thanos not snapped half the population originally
the emergence would have happened about a week
after avengers infinity war so they were still
going to have a downer ending after that movie no
matter what r.i.p although connecting this back to
the loki series he who remains king came from
earth in the distant future so had it come to
that he who remains probably would have intervened
altering the course of history so that he could be
born like he wouldn't be erased from existence if
the earth was destroyed but all that means is that
it takes between seven and eight billion people to
fully hatch a new celestial another connection to
ego the living planet because he is a celestial as
well this whole plan of seeding other planets with
celestial seeds is kind of what ego the living
planet was doing with his seeds on other worlds
although his mission was kind of a twisted
version of what arishem the judge was doing
that's also another in the celestial armor like
if the celestials are so powerful they have this
ultimate grand design then how do you explain
rogue celestials like you the living planet
that's why you're meant to question everything
that arishem the judge says during the movie like
this is not the whole truth i feel like
you're lying to me about everything now
they start the movie with a roster of 10 eternals
and they explain that it's always been this team
going to each different planet together they've
been hurt they've been killed in previous
missions but they're always repaired they always
have their memories wiped after each mission
except for ajac at the end of the movie when they
sort of merge their energy with timoth's energy
they also claimed that they've done this before
too and that's how in most cases they've survived
each emergence but the main roster in this movie
is the basic main roster of jack kirby's original
eternals comic book but they changed some of
the relationships and some of the betrayals in
the movie is ikaris who turns on the team in the
comics that's usually druid all the eternals are
so powerful that all the people of earth worship
them as gods they inspire many of the modern day
myths about ancient gods like sprite is the one
who created the greek legend of icarus who flew
too close to the sun they also referenced that
again a couple times in the movie like he attacks
from the sun line of sight in the opening battle
and at the end of the movie he literally flies
into the sun to kill himself as a way to tone for
what he's done but because at the end of the movie
arishem the judge takes them back to the world
forge where he created them in the first place it
would be super easy for him to 3d print a new copy
of ikaris and because he explains that he keeps
all their memories that he downloads in storage
there they can always just upload those memories
to a new ikaris body so they could bring richard
madden back in a future movie if they want to a
lot of you've also asked why the eternals all look
so different why do they have different accents
why are some of them out of shape why is makkari
deaf if they're all meant to be these perfect op
super powerful beings mostly the idea is the irish
and the judge created them to blend in with the
populations of each planet that they go to there's
a more complicated explanation for why makkari
is deaf in the comics but because the way they
explain thena's memory problems are the result
of some glitches during their reboot cycle process
i think you could also blame makkari being deaf
on something like that they cannot have children
as they exist in this form at least early in the
movie so phastos' son here is probably adopted
but now you ask about thanos and his brother
eros how can they be the children of two eternals
from titan if eternals can't have children i think
the answer is in sprite's ending so sersi uses
the power of the uni-mind she has left over to
change sprite into a more human form if it wasn't
clear sprite still has all of her powers it's just
that she ages like a human she has all their
weaknesses now like she could get a common cold
something similar probably happened to thanos's
parents they were changed in a way that allowed
them to conceive but fundamentally thanos and
his brother arose harry styles are both eternals
the reason why thanos is a purple space grimace
with the nutsack chin is because in the comics
he was born with a deviant mutation but he's
still an eternal as they bring harry styles
back in future movies as the eros starfox
character more characters will probably ask
him questions about thanos in his relationship
in marvel we'll probably just use that as an
opportunity to answer a lot of those details and
questions people have about thanos backstory after
their big opening battle with the deviants sersi
changes the dagger gives it to the early human
and then they reference it again after the big
time jump to present day when she's in london and
sees it on the billboard as part of this museum
exhibit the title in the weapon itself artifacts
that shape human history is a reference to the
way they shaped the course of human evolution by
giving them technology over the years like phastos
was involved in the creation of the atomic bomb
they also have a big argument about this later
when they realize the truth of their mission that
they've been helping propagate war because war
leads to other advancements in technology that
helps the population grow even faster sersi speaks
to the statue of charles darwin when she's rushing
in calling him charlie because she knew him when
he was alive the funny thing about the museum here
the paintings all the statues the exhibits all
these famous people from history she would have
known them when they were alive like she would
have been their senpai at some point later when
they're celebrating and sersi gives dane whitman
his family's ring from the middle ages it has the
crest of the black knight on it the same crest
that's on the case of the ebony blade in the
post credit scene it's implied that she lied about
getting it on ebay like she actually probably got
it from camelot in the original black knights
or percy dane whitman's ancestor because they
said all the eternals lived in camelot with king
arthur and his court before its fall makkari even
straight up joint excalibur and has it on their
ship there's this big running joke about makkari
just having sticky fingers through the film just
stealing all kinds of treasures and artifacts as
they go along through history so their ship the
domo is just full of all kinds of treasure but the
original black knight comes from camelot the ebony
blade itself was forged by merlin so for example
merlin another doctor strange connection because
kit harington's dane whitman name drops doctor
strange merlin was probably the sorcerer supreme
of the middle ages when she rushes into the
classroom too dane whitman is giving that lecture
about the seeds of perfection that's a reference
to the celestial seeds around the universe that
arishem the judge sent out also a reference
to the celestial orb inside sersi the seed of
perfection that helps her become super op through
the uni-mind changing tiamat into stone that also
connects to sersi's lecture about apex predators
because that in itself is also a reference to the
celestials they are meant to be the apex predators
of the mcu currently the reason dane whitman is
referencing doctor strange though so casually is
because at this point after the events of avengers
end game it's about eight months or so after
avengers end game this is happening around the
same time spider-man far from home is happening
at this point in history after avengers end
game in the blip all the avengers have become
pop culture heroes everybody around the planet
knows about thanos the infinity gauntlet and the
avengers time heist mission when the new deviant
attacks them they explained that it's evolved
because it fed on ajak cosmic energy thanks to
kro. Kro fed on ajak's energy then kro sort of
fed the other deviants further evolving them the
major difference between deviants and eternals
in the movie is that deviants were created as
fully organic life forms capable of evolving
based on the things that they kill and consume
arishem claims that this is the reason why he
can't control them any more because they continue
to evolve and become more and more powerful that's
why he said he wanted to create the eternals to
be cosmic robots incapable of evolving although
sersi proves that to be false when she's able
to change sprite into a human later in the movie
they make all kinds of superman references
when ikaris comes in and saves them from the
deviant there's no rule about them referencing
batman and superman in marvel movies or dc stuff
because later they also do reference batman when
he's talking about karoon and kingo's relationship
like you are his alfred to kingo's batman they
reference marvel movies inside dc tv shows all
the time so this happens both ways both in dc
movies and in marvel movies the director also said
their depiction of ikaris in the movie was based
on zack snyder's man of steel movie like they
created this version of ikaris in the movie in the
mcu to be kind of like their version of superman
they have a bit of a game of thrones reference
when dane whitman meets ikaris for the first time
because kit harington and richard madden played
jon snow and rob stark the last time that they saw
each other in game of thrones he said next time
i see you you'll be dressed in black and now he's
playing the black knight so technically he wasn't
wrong also in the movie they have a love triangle
with a character named sersi even though it's
spelled differently from game of thrones cersei
the other big game of thrones reference is
actually through the soundtrack so rameen javadi
did the soundtrack for the eternals the music
he also did the music for game of thrones
they explained the real reason why ikaris left
sersi so many hundreds of years ago is because
he learned the truth about their mission in the
emergence from ajak after they all went their
separate ways during the big spanish assault
on the aztecs and it just broke him inside he
couldn't deal with it and he isolated himself
from all the other eternals sersi then explains
everything to dane whitman about their backstory
why they didn't help fight thanos during avengers
end game or during any of the other wars because
irish and the judge ordered them not to unless
deviants started killing off humans because again
it's all about just increasing the population
as fast as possible then they start intercutting
flashbacks with the present day road trip as they
go around uniting the rest of the team the next
one being to ancient babylon they also explained
that they hid their ship the domo inside the very
foundation of babylon like their ship is part of
the city itself just hidden by the buildings and
later it's implied that they never bothered to
move it the ship was just slowly buried underneath
all the changing landscape over many hundreds of
years like when they go back to enter it in
present day it's been in the same place that
babylon was this whole time when ajak contacts
arishem that first time in the movie and says the
other eternals across the universe will learn from
their success he's talking about their ability to
grow the population on earth faster like hey
we found some tricks to boost the population
even quicker meaning each new celestial could
be born even faster it's all about that cosmic
supply chain got to get those celestials off the
line faster and faster they find ajak's dead body
but later with all the time jumps we find out that
it was ikaris who killed her to prevent her from
stopping the emergence because he's so committed
to heirsham in the celestial's dogma that he'll
do anything to see their plan succeed they try to
play it during the movie like he's really torn up
about it like he cares about all of his fellow
teammates like he's still in love with sersi he
didn't stop loving her but he won't defy irish and
the judge and the other celestials when they go to
get gilgamesh and thena they explain more about
her memory problems we eventually learned that it
was all part of this previous memory extraction
reboot cycle there was some glitch during that
and she's just starting to remember all
the previous worlds that they've been on
centauri 6 was the planet that they were on right
before they came to earth like the last mission
they went on they say there are a couple ways to
fix her memory like they could either wipe her
completely which she says that she doesn't want
to do because she wants to remember everything
but because arishem takes them back to the world
forge they could wipe her memory there like reset
her then re-upload all the old memories
that arishem stores there into that body
like using windows restore with a backup hard
drive when druid takes the aztecs and walks
off into the jungle to form his little community
this is also a reference to the disappearance of
the aztec culture but in the mcu druid says he's
been using his power to protect these people for
hundreds of years so they're the ancestors
of the original aztecs from this city here
and he's just been keeping anyone from the outside
world from interfering with their community from
this whole time sort of like a hardcore version
of what wakanda has been doing in present day
when they go to get kingo he's in the middle of
making a bollywood movie based on their adventures
as the eternal's team so he's making an eternal
movie inside the eternals movie calling it the
legend of ikaris playing ikaris himself later he
also tries to make a separate documentary eternals
movie within the eternal movie so that the world
will just eventually know the truth about them
joking that they'll finally know the truth about
the shadow warrior and the funny thing about all
of kingo's bollywood movies that he's been making
recently this franchise that he's been making
the shadow warrior sequels is that they're meant
to be bollywood versions of all the marvel movies
so it's a bit of a funny meta easter egg for the
infinity saga movies like when karoon references
the line from the shadow warrior 2 voyage of time
that's a reference to avengers end game the quote
about protecting your family avengers end game
was all about bringing everyone's families back
they also kind of foreshadowed the blade cameo
scene in the post-credits scene with mahershala
ali when kingo says karoon tried to stake him in
the heart thinking that he was a vampire vampires
have been referenced a couple times in different
mcu movies at this point he also says that he's
been pretending to be his own children throughout
history creating the greatest bollywood dynasty
in history and just like makkari collects treasure
and artifacts from their adventures across history
kingo also seems like he owns the original captain
america shield from his uso tour before he got his
vibranium shield when he's making that documentary
he references most of the other avengers like
spider-man iron man captain america he also says
that thor used to follow him around when thor was
a little kid because thor's only about 1500 years
old and kingo is millions of years old maybe they
can have a reference to that in the next avengers
movie when they cross over like thor be like oh
you're that guy yeah i remember you there is a
deleted scene that didn't make the final cut of
the movie from all the trailers where ikaris says
eternals assemble like avengers assemble there are
many different avengers references throughout
the film like when they're talking about the
events of avengers end game in the new avengers
team saying that now that captain america and
iron man are gone who's gonna lead the new team
who's gonna be on that team it's marvel setting
up the eternals crossing over with the avengers in
avengers 5 but not all of them will be in avengers
5 like half of them die during this movie and
only a couple of them will probably show up at
any one time like kid harington's black knight
will come back sersi will probably be in that
next avengers movie maybe a couple others will
get cameo scenes but gilgamesh has been living
with nina taking care of her because of her memory
problems it's implied that they had a relationship
at some point in history because he loved her then
when sersi learns about the emergence and tiamat
from arishem. Tiamat's story is basically
right out of the neil gaiman eternals run
during that they called him the dreaming celestial
in this movie they try to find a way to get him to
go back to sleep sersi accomplishes that with
a similar trick as they used in the comic book
once kro shows up and kills gilgamesh they
explain that as he consumes their cosmic
energy he also gains all their memories and his
story was a little muddled during the film if
you couldn't tell that's bill skarsgard playing
the character or doing the voice he is the son in
real life of stellan skarsgard who plays eric
selvig in the mcu so keeping it in the family
but his whole thing is that he doesn't care about
the earth doesn't care about humans he just wants
revenge against the celestials but if there was
any question about that yes he is dead at the end
of the movie he couldn't heal that wound then they
go to get fastest who's living with his family
i've already explained the superman reference that
they make here but they also reference vibranium
wakanda the black panther movie celestials can
use vibranium to form their bodies so i think it's
implied that had the emergence actually happened
tima could have wound up using the vibranium mound
to strengthen himself there's also a big star wars
easter egg here too they reference star wars many
times during most of the recent marvel movies then
when they finally go back to this they see all the
treasure that makkari has been collecting over the
years i've already explained the excalibur and the
ebony blade reference for king arthur and camelot
they explained that she's been living on the ship
this whole time since they all split then a lot of
you asked about phastos' bracelets that he creates
so he creates one version then ikaris breaks
those then he uses sersi orb to create them again
a lot of you've asked if the bracelets are
connected to the 10 rings of power from the
shang chi movie there's always possible that
there's a connection through the celestials the
eternals but the 10 rings don't look anything
like the bracelets that phastos creates
and they function completely differently in
the type of energy that they channel looks
completely different from the energy that shang
chi gives off when he's wielding the ten rings
so right now i think that the ten rings are
supposed to be something that's totally different
the uni-mind that he talks about is a jack kirby
thing from the original eternals comics they all
have the ability to form their minds into a single
consciousness becoming super powerful together
as a group the more minds that combine into the
uni-mind the more powerful it becomes so that's
the whole idea i think with future eternal sequels
them finding other eternals to help them forming
a larger uni-mind giving them the power they need
to defeat irish and the judge in some of the other
celestials the place where tement emerges from and
where they turn him to stone where he resides now
seems like it's somewhere in the atlantic near
brazil because she passed through rio de janeiro
right before arriving at timoth's location a lot
of you've asked about this too like there's a
giant stone celestial in the earth now will they
reference that in future movies i think of course
they're going to reference that in some future
movies i've also heard some reports that the
consequences of what happens here with the ocean
and teammate will affect what's happening with
atlantis and neymar storyline during black panther
2. after the big wtf ikaris betrayal they have
their big final fight ikaris destroys their ship
like it's no big deal phastos says he repaired it
so that the other eternals could use it to go on
their mission to find the other eternals around
the universe there are couple easter eggs during
this big final boss fight when ikaris breaks free
of phastos' chains the shot of him blasting his
eye beams straight up at the sky as a reference to
this comic book cover and i've already explained
how they're able to use tema's energy to fully
change him into stone how sersi uses what's left
of the extra power to change sprite into a human
and like i said ikaris does die when he flies
into the sun paying off the greek legend of ikaris
flying too close to the sun then at the end of
the film they wind up sending sprite to go live
with kingo but they're making her go back to
school just to blend in like she already knows
everything she needs to know like she doesn't need
to relearn math and history again kingo goes back
to making his eternals movie inside the eternals
movie the legend of ikaris and dane whitman tries
to tell sersi about the truth of his family the
black knight the ebony blade until ershan the
judge rolls up to take the other eternals back to
the celestial world forge to determine whether or
not the earth is worthy to continue existing just
based on their memories but arishemexplains that
he's willing to give the earth the benefit of the
doubt but if he determines from their memories
that humans suck balls then the celestial host
will come back to judge the planet and destroy it
that's basically what's happening during this
guardians of the galaxy east on the searcher scene
then the mid-credit scene picks up after a
few weeks have gone by so small time jump
druid thena and makkari complained that they
haven't found any signs of other eternals
around the universe yet and they haven't heard
back from the team members who stayed on earth
now we know why but they don't find out what
happened till pip the troll and eros show up
they both teleport in using technology similar
to the bifrost that's why it has the same rainbow
effect as the bifrost and thor movies i did a
whole separate video for this scene in the black
knight post credit scene so i'll link that at
the end of this and down below in the description
but the idea is that patton oswalt is pip the
troll from the infinity gauntlet thanos storyline
and harry styles is eros or starfox whatever you
want to call him inside the mcu now he confirms
that he's thanos' younger brother prince of
titan knave of hearts that's just a reference
to his powers in the comics powers to make people
horny on main he's another prime eternal just like
ajak just like sersi and says he's going to
use his orb to help them rescue their friends
from the celestial world forge and irishman the
judge that's also a plot that they'll cover in the
sequel movies but harry styles eros might cameo
and other space-based marvel movies like guardians
of the galaxy 3 or captain marvel 2 or a nova
movie any theoretical space-based marvel movie
there's way more easter eggs and references going
on during this mid credits scene so just watch
my other video about it to learn about all them
during the post credit scene they reveal the real
mcu ebony blade kid harington's dane whitman is
getting ready to take up the mantle of the black
knight from his uncle this room where he is where
the ebony blade is is inside his uncle's castle
in the comics his uncle was the evil version of
the black knight in avengers villain when he lay
dying he leaves everything he owns to dane whitman
and when he's taking stock of everything inside
the castle he finds a secret room that contains
the ebony blade picks it up becoming the next
black knight in their family on the case there's
a phrase in latin that reads moore's mighty lucrum
death is my reward that's a reference to the
curse of the ebony blade the curse of their family
kit harington referred to it as an addiction
to the blade the blade gives the wilder these
crazy powers but it also comes with a bloodlust
eventually you wind up being consumed with so
much berserker rage you just turn on everyone it's
implied that that's what happened to his uncle and
why he had such a strained relationship with him
in the movie earlier in the movie sersi had said
you always wanted to make up with your uncle now's
the time to do that the blade is whispering to him
as he prepares to touch it the voices are all the
souls that it's collected it basically reaps the
souls of every once that's killed by the blade the
surface of the blade has fluidic properties it's
alive kind of like the necro sword and just before
he touches it off screen you hear mahershala ali
mcu blade say are you sure you're ready for that
dane whitman and the reason why they probably
wanted to put blade in this black knight post
credit scene is to help set up the mcu blade
movie and imply that kid harington's black knight
will show up in that blade movie like black knight
vampire hunter kit harington using the ebony blade
to fight vampires with blade kevin feige has also
revealed that kit harington will show up in that
next avengers 5 movie eventually but it sounds
like the blade movie is the next place we'll see
him there's also a whole lot more going on in this
post-credits scene that i cover in that separate
post-credits scene video i talk about the powers
and abilities that you get from the blade so like
i said there's a link for that video at the end of
this and down in the description but if you did
spot any huge easter eggs that i didn't cover
in this video or in my last video just write them
below in the description i will do separate deep
dive videos on starfox and the black knight later
this weekend so make sure you have alerts enabled
for my channel so you don't miss those there's
still a lot of big stuff to talk about so just
leave all your requests in the comments below
congratulations savitar god of speed you're the
giveaway winner from my last big video please
email me on the about page of my channel so i
can get your contact details everyone click here
for that full eternals post credit scene and mid
credit scene video and click here to learn how
thanos saved the avengers from the celestials
thank you so much for watching everyone stay
safe and i'll see you guys in the next one!